do you know what you were doing one year
ago
7 a.m eastern time we do well yeah i
hope they were watching us i hope they
were watching part of a tradition you
know they watch every morning every
morning at 7 00 am i thinking that's the
day we became your favorite morning show
you're welcome it was one year ago today
that we launched cbs mornings right here
in this brand new studio with a new look
and a new co-host his name is nathaniel
eugene burleson but we just call him
nate hey nate
hey what's up yeah a year ago i started
a new job with some co-workers that are
now like family to me i love you guys
congratulations on the anniversary
i'm sorry you weren't here to enjoy the
lunchable
mosaic
because gisele just walked in who does
my hair says well i've never seen one of
those that's different it's very
different here at cbs morning and they
do this job for the show that has
everything and speaking of everything
nate you've got a house that's got
everything and to celebrate we got to
let our viewers know that you invited
all of us over
the three of us about forty of our
closest friends as well they invited us
tony just showed up we didn't show up
and only vlad was smart enough to bring
a bottle of wine uh he bought he had the
drinks i had the food i think it's fair
to say gail what did you provide exactly
my appetite the appetizer and you're my
pleasing personality sous chef gayle
king brought the party people
nate burla said we're
[Music]
here i knew that was true
i brought my appetite are you ready to
eat
i'm eating
i've invited you guys here because we've
been working so much we have never had a
chance to be here at the same time so i
appreciate you guys showing up the grill
is hot all right let's get this one
[Music]
what do you do cut it in half just tear
it off the stem like this nate's got
gold
knives so i'm being very delicate how
long will it take before our meal is
ready
asking for a friend
[Music]
you guys know where i got this from
cbs deals damn right no way no
[Music]
all right we're ready for battle
here
[Music]
one last look
[Music]
i don't think i've ever done this before
in my life lifted up a grill
and put anything on it
god this makes me wish i could cook
all right mr cruz give us your best
cocktail
[Music]
oh that tastes like vacation
get it while it's hot does anyone want
the potatoes i made
crickets salad's going real fast
so many people will reach out to me on
social media and they'll say you guys
really seem like you're friends and i'm
like we actually hang out outside of
work yeah like we actually do like each
other yeah yeah if you had to pick a
couple of stories that over the course
of the year that really stuck out to you
either something that you've covered or
a guest that we've had on the show i
know it's hard because the new cycle
moves so quickly you know you're
constantly thinking about what's next
yeah yeah but you were in poland
covering the war in ukraine but after
walking for days and for miles what
people really want
is just a place to sit down and get warm
tony you have this way of telling these
stories that are
stories that have been told before but
you do something different about it you
put the audience in the shoes of people
who are just like them she didn't
deserve that no she did it
oh she didn't
that's what the show's all about right
it's about making a connection you are
more than just wallpaper to them you're
a part of their family you're at their
breakfast table and they say that all
the time all the time
i wake up with you yes or if you're not
there where is nate where's blood
where's tony when are they coming back
people real is it raining
yeah it is which is why we're in we just
made it inside
[Music]
you can't program camaraderie you cannot
do that it's either it's there or it
isn't
and i think for us it gelled very
quickly what's your name is nate
burleson nate burlington around here we
call him aka nate the great let's
flashback
when you first came on the show you did
you filled in for vlad and what to watch
week right come on
i was doing good
more shorts on day one a hat and a hat
we all noticed that out but i also
didn't want to blend in you know what i
mean i'm a wide receiver we're divas
let's just keep it real okay i never
feel bored at this job ever even if it's
a slow news day i still never feel
better i watch it even though i'm on the
show every day i watch it still as a
viewer as a viewer like when you did
your interview with michael j fox i mean
he drove me a fox fan and that was so
powerful do you remember
that moment when you guys cried together
oh yeah absolutely well because she said
why i came for the doctors and i
obviously looked like i just got hit by
a truck and she said what happened i
said
i have parkinson's you with megan the
stallion i mean we learned things that
we didn't know it shouldn't have got
this crazy it shouldn't have escalated
towards right that it did that's
actually the great thing about this job
i would say it's the best job in the
world because you get to go to places
everyone doesn't get to go get to talk
to people not everyone can talk to right
and you get to ask the questions of
people in power
that other people have on their mind
there will be severe and swift
consequences that there will be he
didn't seem to say that yesterday though
at the news conference that's why
there's some that's why i think
clarification is needed i really do
believe you can ask any question
you just have to have the right setting
the right tone the right time jennifer
should i expect an invitation anytime
soon to a wedding
anything
there was one guy that came in and we
all collectively knew
like he's on his way to something bigger
like the world did
when john batiste
does stephen colbert need to look for a
new band leader
does he need to take applications well i
do know this yesterday's price ain't
today's price giveaway
that's a fact
the moment with henry winkler can i just
tell you
that that meant yes
[Music]
i'm so happy to see you but you really i
mean your whole face just lights up when
there's something that really delights
you one of my favorite moments uh for
some reason we had a football helmet in
the center of the table commanders in
the super bowl
[Music]
boys i know they were running around
it was like the movie brothers did we
just become
[Music]
the last year has been whirlwind these
are long days and early mornings gail if
i'm falling asleep here elbow me in the
ribs all right don't just let me go out
no i'm going to rock you to my bosom
it's okay or that okay
there's times when we look at each other
and we see the fatigue
but we turn the switch on one because we
appreciate the job yeah and two because
the viewer is sitting there waiting but
to us your family and that's why we left
that seat open for you
don't tell a friend you're invited
cheers
[Music]
that was a lovely afternoon nate
burleson we all walked out of there
drooling about your house saying we want
to stay here you are clearly the host
with the most
well thank you i appreciate that and i
appreciate you guys joining us
yes shout out to my wife shout out to my
wife that's right you know i i know this
is a celebration but i couldn't help but
to get emotional we we do have a great
job and we have so much fun and there is
so much love not just with us but also
everybody else behind the scenes so i
want to say thank you to the team the
cbs family